the physical locations are incredibly
important for Game of Thrones the
characters are defined by the worlds in
which they come we all do love to go to
Iceland it's just beautiful
it's beautiful every day that Sun comes
up it's a new gift to us really no
matter how much visual effects may play
a part in this we have a real location
then what you can imagine becomes more
real so the trick is working out where
these playgrounds are going to be every
year is nice to come back and then you
read it and you go oh my god really it
just gives it a sense of reality you
know to get that journey that sense of
them tracking across this landscape we
need to come to a landscape like it we
can't paint it in or film it in Belfast
the joy of my job is we get to come to
these locations that are just it's
extraordinary as wonderful as Belfast is
it can get a spectacular sweep of
locations and just as you can Iceland in
Belfast you can't get the warm light the
different terrain and the vegetation
that you get in Spain Spain I'm
everywhere and it's amazing just it's
glorious it kind of takes your breath
away you never feel like you're in a
green-screen world when you shoot you
never do you always set a real location
[Music]
remember when Chris showed me a picture
from Iceland when I first came on the
show and I said that's what we need to
start doing we need that bigger vistas
you know that's what this show demands
Ison's always been north of the wall
since season two and I think you'll find
landscapes like this wouldn't have been
imagined for map paintings and yes we've
come it's very challenging to shoot in
Iceland you know can be very cold and
that's hard guys are pulling focus with
the freezing fingers I don't know how
they do it light is the giver that's the
non-changing thing it'll always be less
light in the winter here you are on the
set waiting for the Sun to rise once it
rises you only have about five hours to
shoot and so we just haul ass and try to
shoot as fast as we can
I something magical about some luck too
sir and then the life appears you see
what you're shooting this is going to
make the episode what it is incredible
and I think to give North that kind of
wild quality Iceland is the only place
to be when we left Spain last year we
weren't even sure that we were coming
back because we weren't sure where the
season was going so it was quite
exciting when the outlines come up
though actually we were going to have to
look for a lot of this stuff in Spain
again
the great thing about Spain is that
there's so many different looks within
one country has know some green lost
lamb like this - Moorish architecture -
other traditional architecture that we
can get King's Landing here as well so
Spain as a country has a massive
diversity of rotations I've coming to
this location it could have been any
number of countries something kind of
ancient and epic about it it's an
amazing place to come a really
interesting same as like locations that
you almost can't believe are just here
they're so beautiful that you're like oh
someone built this for the show and it's
not this is just there
you
if you believe the world too much people
are living and we're actually filming
you believe more about the stories and
about the characters it's just such a
major factor in why this show is worked
and I'm stunned every time I come on to
a new set an each year we get spoiled
and spoiled and spoils and I'm very very
very lucky and why gets doing
Spain makes it like a holiday this is
not a bad place to work is it this is
like amazing amazing way to spend the
day of work this is our third year
shooting here it gets better every year
and locations I live in New York City
which is this is breasted
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie new Game of
Thrones preview let's break it down just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far
there's a new round of the giveaway for
the HBO now subscription all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so there's a
couple really big things they show up in
this one are the lands of always winter
you even see a slate that says something
from episode 6 but they're just
highlighting the locations that they
film at Iceland in Spain which is where
they've been before a lot but so much is
happening up closer to the north that a
lot of the scenes that they're filming
aren't the traditional scenes they
filmed in those places so like they talk
about a bunch of the new castles that
they had to find while there were in
Spain they used to film a lot of stuff
in Dubrovnik for King's Landing for
instance but then they move that to
Spain so you see them filming a lot of
the same locations in the same country
so you get like Daenerys Marine stuff
from last season but you also get King's
Landing stuff within the same country so
now because we're in Westeros and
Daenerys is going to be fighting between
the South the north the East the West
you just see a bunch of that play out
across this behind-the-scenes footage so
let's just break it down as we go
through the early stuff I mentioned with
the slate here from episode 7 this is
very clearly up beyond north of the wall
most of the Iceland stuff used to just
be for the wildling things when Jon Snow
was trying to infiltrate them during
season 3 the scenes that are shot in and
around the wall like all this stuff with
a three-eyed Raven with brand trying to
escape the death of Hodor this is all
Iceland stuff but you see a lot of this
terrain this is stuff that we haven't
seen since Jon Snow was with those
wildlings in season 3 they're going so
much further north than they've ever
gone before in it's very reminiscent of
that scene during season 4 where the
white Walker was taking Craster's son to
be turned into a new white Walker by the
night King so you don't see Jon Snow and
his wildling furs yet but you do see
torment so this looks like it's part of
this scene from the trailer here where
they're entering the frozen north but
then you see a lot of Tyrion and what
looks like scenes around Dragonstone
like where he's standing on this open
plain watching the Dragons fly around
you see them tracking him with his big
green screen so you have to imagine
there's a giant dragon flying in his
field of vision here there's a bunch of
Daenerys entering the beach I love the
look on a million karke space to like
see
so excited to be doing this they're
going to be so bummed out after they
finished filming season eight most of
this terrain here reminds me of the
Tower of joy so this might be happening
closer to door with some of those big
campaigns there'll be a couple really
big Lannister battles and I think just
in order to make the Lannisters feel
like a big threat they will get a couple
big wins because in the other
behind-the-scenes trailer that I posted
the other day you actually spot olaria
sand in Chains with Cersei way back
behind here so at some point Cersei will
capture one of the sand snakes so that
just means that there will be a
Lannister victory it's not going to be
all one-sided
even though Daenerys has her dragons
mass and I here sitting next to this
plant life here just kind of backs that
up this looks like the gardens and Dorne
you see a little bit of Jon Snow that's
further south he's not in costume in
this shot either so you just have to
remember that the characters will be
moving around quite a bit probably
Daenerys the most just because she's
starting out in the south and she's
making her way all the way up to the
north there's a couple more Dornish
castles and probably the biggest reveal
is this shot of what looks like the
ruins of the dragon pit in King's
Landing they did say that they would be
filming a location that sounded like
that and this reminds me of daznak spit
back in marine but this is going to be a
different location they're not going
back to marine this is all taking place
in Westeros so it seems like there will
be some scenes with Daenerys in King's
Landing whether or not that happens
early in the season late in the season
remains to be seen but it sounds like
Cersei is going to hold out quite a bit
so I'm not expecting this to happen
until much much later well let me know
which location you're most excited about
honestly the dragon pit just has so much
history behind it but I cannot wait to
see what craziness happens with tormund
in John's group north of the wall so
just because the slate says episode 6
doesn't mean it'll take that long for
them to get up there but it does imply
that they're going to be ending on a big
cliffhanger in the north which i think
would be a great way to push into season
8 so you have all these wars happening
in the South you have Daenerys Cersei
gained a couple victories eventually
they make their way north and they end
on a big oh my god are they going to
live are they going to die moment but
let me know what do you think that
cliffhanger is going to be because this
is episode 6 then it sounds like episode
7 is there's going to be a continuation
of this believe all your requests for
Game of Thrones bonus for
in the comments below we'll probably get
a proper trailer either next week or the
week after that because we'll be about
four weeks out from the season
premiering usually when we get about
four weeks out is when they really start
dropping promos so a whole bunch more
Game of Thrones coming I'll announce the
winner that giveaway the next time I
post a game of Thrones videos that'll be
on Sunday while you wait for that click
here for that other behind-the-scenes
trailer and you can click here for all
my other promo videos thank you so much
for watching let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight
you